[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non chère madame je suis venu parce que
vous avez insisté et je vous ai apporté
le dossier il contient les preuves
irréfutables de la mort de votre genre
mais ces télégrammes signé daniel tout
le monde se souvient de son prénom
les journaux ont assez parlé de daniel
bernard il y a 6 ans au moment de sa
tragique disparition en amazonie et nous
voyons tous les jours des gens qui se
délecte aux plaisanteries maker broye au
bassin
ça c'est bien vrai bref une fois je
faisais mes 28 jours au camp de jal en
tout cas ça fait pas très bien connu
parce que c'est tout à fait dans sa
manière arriverais là dit roy 6 12
heures air france tous sa veine
essentiel stop vous dirais le reste de
vie voir daniel c'est tout lui savait
l'essentiel qu'est ce que nous savons
d'essentiel pressé du moment qui sait
que nous savons c'est que nous savons
non assurent même si ce télégramme
n'était pas signé ce jour dès que les
nuits fraîches avec une impression et
permettez moi de vous répondre que le
skill d'un télégramme est un argument de
peu de poids au regard des conclusions
objectives de l'autorité judiciaire si
celle ci a déclaré que daniel bernard
votre gendre était mort c'est qu'il est
mort on n'a pas retrouvé le corps
récemment à mes yeux le fait même que
son corps n'est pas été retrouvé donne à
son acte de décès une valeur encore plus
probant comment cela il est pratiquement
impossible d'obtenir une transcription
de décès près les registres de l'état
civil
si on devra présenter le corps il ya des
instances qui sont encore depuis plus de
20 ans or en ce qui nous concerne le
tribunal a statué le 8 juillet 1974
alors que la disparition remontait à
janvier 1973 c'est à dire au bout d'un
an et demi à peine c'est donc que les
preuves étaient formels et informels et
les témoignages de deux indiens de deux
guides indien qui avait été fournie à
l'expédition martinon par les autorités
équatoriennes et qui l'ont vu se noyer
jeunes à leurs dépositions et qu'elle
longue balle qu'il ces gens là sont les
comprendre c'est le ministre mauricien
mmm
ils savent pas écrire ya pas de
dictionnaire
n'interrompt pas tout le temps m
d'ailleurs leurs dépositions était
confirmée par celle du professeur martin
ont chef de l'expédition mandaté par la
société de géographie officier de la
légion d'honneur il était à 100 au
moment de l'accident il n'a rien vu ce
sont les indiens pour raconter oui mais
il s'est porté immédiatement sur les
lieux de la noyade et il a longuement
exploré le fleuve en amont et en aval
sonrier retrouver même pas le cas y'a et
donc il ya des ballons dans des pointes
c'est un submersible
alors même s'il était brisée at the
bridge va comme ça à caillac surtout
celui-là la violence soigner tout
particulièrement la publicité de la
maison il s'agit bien de cela nous nous
pensions à la sécurité de notre gens
d'être en compagnon je l'entends du et
permettez moi d'ajouter que même si
votre gendre avait échappé je ne vois
pas comment à cet accident
il se trouvait dans une contrée des plus
inhospitalières habité seulement par
leur art tribu d'indiens
particulièrement sauvage c'est jivaro
pratique encore la réduction des têtes
un homme blanc désarmé perdu dans la
forêt vierge n'aurait vraiment que très
peu de chances de survivre et ils nous
en parler tout le temps vous savez de
ces réducteurs de têtes
il y avait des livres il y en avait il y
en avait y en avait sept titres est de
quitter white est plus grosse que le
point julien ne rappelle pas toutes ces
horreurs je n'y ai déjà content si
frémit à la pensée que ma fille aurait
pu être le moment de l'arrivée du
télégramme évidemment pourrait le
souhaiter un choc
ben pour son bien et c'est bien ce qui
met pour vente s'est investi ce serait
peut-être même pas remariée évidemment
bénisse et le ciel de l'avoir épargnée
cette émotion
et puisque vous m'avez demandé conseil
je vous engage vivement à ne rien lui
dire vous voyez vous avez été victime d'
un mystificateur ça crève les yeux que
si j'étais aussi sur deux trouve une
place tout à l'heure devant mon étude
j'aimerais bien savoir rabbit tous ces
gens qui laissent leur voiture devant ma
porte du matin au soir j'ai regardé la
mienne devant chez eux
il va y avoir de la place je suis
heureux
je vous salue et avant de parcourir
avant de partir j'avais de la vie vous
allez visionner avec le nom je souhaite
avec plaisir mais il va être midi
justement c'est leur idéal pour déjeuner
mais cinq coups vers la côte et non je
vous assure
qu'est ce que c'est que c'était le
télégramme oui grosse on m'a dit qu'il
était arrivé à telegraph
pour moi à oui je sais rien
comment se situe la nouvelle non ah non
je me serais pas permis n'ont jamais
trouvé duvel qui nous a conseillé à ses
maîtres d'art oui oui oui
si vous voulez me faire plaisir vous
lâcher feriez pas pour en prendre
connaissance
wa tumba trygg data grammes de kif au
sort du dedans mauvais présent c'est moi
qui l'ait décacheté où est il mais à
quoi bon puisque maître barbier duval se
dit un non non je veux savoir de quoi il
s'agit montrez lui vient elle verra bien
que ce n'est pas sérieux ça vaut
peut-être mieux
à nier quoi ça alors hop c'est un peu
gros mon rêve de cette nuit est effacé
je rentrais pour déjeuner il règne me
disais bonjour d'alien je me regarder
dans une glace et je ressemblais à
daniel mais avec une toute petite tête
mais tout en suisse et curieux il ya
cinq minutes en ne recommence pas
daniel vive vous voyez j'ai tenu à
provoquer tout de suite maître barbier
du mal parce que si c'était vrai tu te
trouverait dans une situation situation
qui serait évidemment déchirante mais je
vous répète que pour ma part je me
refuse à l'envi sa jouer enfin si vous
êtes là il n'ya pas d'inconvénient à
vous poser la question va croiser il
vaut mieux savoir alors au point de vue
légal
qu'est-ce qui se passerait alors là je
vous assure que vous mmes embarrassé
pourquoi le cas n'est pas prévu à 6 ans
les juristes ne sont pas des gens gais
il prévoit toujours le pire mais avant
votre présence c'est la clarté même de
la loi qui me fait mais qu'est ce
qu'elle dit elle dit elle dit que votre
mariage serait annulée le mien a
naturellement et vous trouvez çà naturel
ils sont mariés depuis trois ans aux
yeux de la loi seul le premier mariage
bangalore et ma fille
votre fille redeviendrait housse de
daniel bernard
on vous comprenez pourquoi je voulais
éviter d'aborder ce sujet devant vous
mon pauvre armand ce serait tragique bah
oui ça s'arrête et on ce qui concerne
les questions matérielles la situation
c'est extrêmement compliqué pour
l'instant votre fille est propriétaire
de cette maison et de cette affaire
puisque avant de partir son mari son
premier mari l'avait fait sa légataire
universelle mais s'il était vivant
ce testament se trouverait caduque et le
testateur devrait être renvoyé en
possession de tous ses biens de tous les
biens qu'il possédait au moment de son
départ
non non si j'ai bonne mémoire daniel
bernard sur les instances de feu
monsieur bernard son père avait épousé
votre fille sous le régime de la
séparation bien oui ma fille était sans
fortune alors c'est très net
elle se trouvait au même point la sphère
la maison tous les biens mobiliers et
immobiliers ferait retour en leur état
actuel au seul daniel bernard alors
était actuellement c'est la loi hope
d'ailleurs vous ne subirez en définitive
au 4 juin 10 redevenant les pousses de
daniel bernard
vous continueriez a bénéficié
indirectement de la situation
florissante de cette maison ce qui ne
serait que justice
weedon nommé nommé et moi a pour vous ce
serait différent
vous aviez épouse et vous aussi madame
veuve bernard sous le régime de la
séparation de biens
oui mais est autant qu'il m'en souvienne
vous n'aviez pas à ce moment-là de
fortune personnelle non il était
contremaître sentiers oui c'est
évidemment fâche si vous aviez une
fortune personnelle investi dans la
sphère vous pourriez revendiquer une
part de son augmentation de capital
mais comme ce n'est pas le cas c'est
vous qui seriez le plus gravement lésés
en fait il vous resterait rien vous
savez moi dès l'instant où j'aurais
perdu irène le reste
non c'était sûr il est comme nous dans
ces moments là le voyant tous combien
d'argent et peu de choses à leur place
l'incipit fait le voilà donc je vous ai
donné toutes ses explications pour vous
faire plaisir
mais ma conviction demeure entière so
télégramme n'est qu'une farce odieuse
dont l'auteur mériterait d'être
poursuivi je suis d'ailleurs persuadé
qu'il s'en tiendra là et que vous
n'entendrez plus parler à demi prix à la
voiture qui me rappelle beaucoup la peau
une histoire
ouais ouais bah je voulais rencontrer
une autre fois doit être traité au
bientôt la demie je regrette vivement
une fois accepté votre aimable
invitation mais je vous le rappellera
sûrement un de ces joueurs nous y
comptons bien chère madame merci de vous
être dérangé mais monsieur la moindre
des choses mais au maroc m non ne vous
donnez pas la peine
messieurs en appétit merci voci n'est
attendue et que le lauquet a besoin oui
je sais je sais à bientôt et connaît
bien la noix il ne connaît même que ça
quel être déplaisant et il a fallu que
tu parles de ce télégramme
je ne ferai rien dit et tu ne te serais
pas tourmenté probablement pour rien
beauport probablement pas tu sais
combien je suis intuitive je sens
quelque chose c'était des grains est de
daniel mais nous en voulons toujours au
même pas pourquoi
aurait-il des nouvelles comme ou de 6
ans il faut peut-être à en donner
comment ils pouvaient pas mais s'il
n'était pas mort il était vivant s'il
était vivant il pouvait écrire vous
voyez dans la forêt vierge les boîtes à
lettres accroché à tous les arbres en
plaisant wahaha
mais peut-être malades agonisant on a
venise pas pendant six ans on peut ne
pas se rappeler se rappeler quoi tu vas
rien justement il ya des gens après un
accident et se souviennent de rien la
wii dans tous les hôpitaux
psychiatriques il ya des malades qui ne
soit même plus qu'il se maintient on
avait un film à la télé l'autre jour oui
c'est un prisonnier il a perdu la
mémoire à l'hôpital et c'est pas parce
qu'il était un hôpital qui avait perdu
la mémoire
c'est le contraire c'est parce qu'il
avait perdu club que tu me fatigues et
malade malade
une explication qui explique que rien si
les indiens avaient recueilli mal avant
on l'aurait su il faut quelquefois
logique s'il est vivant
alors qu'on le croit marc depuis six ans
et qu'il a voulu qu'on trois morts
pourquoi aurait-il fait une chose pas
écouté peut-être quelque chose ils
auraient fait ça pour se venger se
venger oui après ce que nous avons fait
pour lui ce serait le comble ou déchargé
de tout souci de toute responsabilité
avec la station et la rive réussi en
justicier monte cristo des torsades
rhône
oui si vous avez tellement l'air d'avoir
peur toutes les deux or tous peuvent se
pose agnel lui qui était si gentil
comment voulez-vous en tout cas il
trouvera à qui parler
ah oui alors il serait bien su à temps
oui
ses bras
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
santé sautez journée sur la vie m'a dit
sauve et puis la tête mais non vous
n'êtes pas la droit d'ouvrir la porte de
métal est toujours pas pardon je sais
pas ce qu'il lui faudrait revenir qu
est-ce qu ici je suis bien là cette
année puis de l'autre comme quoi même
avec les tendres voila voila de tapoter
pas les mains ça ne sert à rien pendant
les cinq mois au début de l'arrêt fait
pas la mouche du coche n'est pas faire
machine y va ça va mieux ça va bien mal
à vouloir reviennent n'ai pas peur je
suis là nous sommes là nous sommes tous
là mais allez vous en vous vivez plus
fait peur ab excusez moi je pensais pas
que ça allait lui produire on entend
parler c'est savoir s'ils n'ont vraiment
navré aller voter c'est vous plusieurs
mots c'est pas une hallucination
il est là alors c'est pas une raison
pour de gros contrats big movie allez
prenez vous n'aviez pas me faire monter
mais le temps devrait peut-être bien de
revenir un peu plus tard - non si après
six ans d'absence en est pas une
demi-heure on n'est pas si tu es toi
alors vous avez failli tuer ma fille
j'espère que vous avez quelque chose à
dire oui j'ai bien sûr vous ne
supportiez tout de même pas qu'on allait
vous faire des compliments
j'étais complètement inconscient ma
parole tu fais le mort pendant 6 ans
sont inquiétés de moi sentant demandé
comment je pourrais vivre toute seule
mais pourquoi voulez vous que je
m'inquiète je me disais larmes en bas tu
vas pas prétendre que tu étais au
courant vous le pouviez vous douté de
rien oui ça nous faisons très attention
il n'y avait rien d'autre
si une fois moi je t'avais ferme
absolument rien je ne lis pas permis oui
vous la mère maquerelle ça c'est fait on
n'est pas au grand air a sauté aux yeux
comme le neo mais de la figure se pose
rarement le puck contremaître et tout ce
qu'elle avait pu trouver
je vais vous dire elle m'a même épousé
ce possible alors je m'en fous
complètement alors je me demande bien
pourquoi vous revenez à bah oui oui tu
n'avais qu'à rester au dessus est quand
on a voulu partir pour cette expédition
en braquant j'ai voulu partir tu m'as
forcée à partir j'ai tout fait pour
obtenir un oui en me disant que j'étais
passé sportif pas assez audacieux pour
tenter une aventure pareille de façon à
bien piquer mon amour propre
d'ailleurs tu me connaissait bien j'ai
marché comme un bébé j'ai même failli
rester parce que vous n'étiez pas de
taille
oui martine on est revenu il n'a pas
chaviré servir avec un kayak bernard
depuis stables et les plus solides du
monde bat parlons-en une belle saloperie
oui il est parti en lambeaux
immédiatement je vous avais dit qui se
déchiraient qu'il fallait mettre cette
épaisseur de tissus ou de 5
c'était aussi mon impression d'abord
comme j'ai que des idées idiotes faisait
garder pour moi tu as aussi bien fait
lors il fallait que je fus un modèle de
série sinon ça ne voulait rien dire oui
et c'était plus sûr ça va je suis revenu
alors c'est raté et toi
tu l'as toucher l'héritage évidemment et
il va falloir lui rendre passons
l'abonné toute la moyenne celle qui
avait dans la caisse et celle que vous
avez gagné depuis sur le dos du pauvre
morts quant au second mariage annulé
était là les refrains numéro 2
qu'est ce que je vais devenir moine aoc
sa envoyer la porte qu'elle a c'est ce
droit vous avez deux marches à moi je
vais procéder cette affaire est pas et
qu'il voulait qu'un sous-ordre ici oui
c'est maman et moi qui avons tout fait
marcher et je le revends mon sens rien
france s'est tapé fort leur notoriété au
mans je voudrais pas vous le mari joue
les 10 à la porte immédiatement et vous
ensuite de pas rasé par asi donc comment
vous appelez ça vous quand j'ai épousé
irs n est pas un sou vous êtes venu vous
installer chez moi vous gaubert chez à
ma table un tapis et même dans la caisse
pendant que je travaillais comme un
[ __ ]
or et vous preniez vos grand air et eau
critiquer tout et on me donnait des
leçons alors maintenant à la porte et
plus vite que ça ne tolérerait pas les
choses mais avec monk et quelque part il
veut que nous avons ne s'est fermé
qu'est ce que tu crois tu fais fanfaron
comme ça mais tu n'es qu'un pantin
nathan a toujours mené par le bout du
nez quand vous n'êtes pas pu y avait
déjà deux ans qu'elle vous tromper avec
armand et j'ai du tempérament à moi
aussi je le prends comme un jeu
quoi comment parce que ça peut faire oui
avec forestier oui c'est le représentant
des hors bord d' évaluer la bête cet
homme-là surtout quand j'arrive
inopinément un bureau il volera vous y
habituer moi j'ai trempé julia toute sa
vie ne s'en porte pas plus mal pour
stars au contraire même sac ça repose
alors témoin même si très bien passer de
toi je m'en passerais encore on va tous
y va un peu fort mais je vous fait pas
peur
h et bien ça surprend ça fait 15 jours
que j'ai tué personne ça commence à
devenir en attendant c'est parce que
elle je la garde à vue aux pompes et
taisez-vous dans si la garderie elle est
perdue justement je la garde comme bones
crois quoi
gomon falaq cerveau les seat geste et
font les femmes de gilles roth n'a pas
la belle font la cuisine naturellement
le ménage les vêtements et puis surtout
les les gros travaux doit elle reste du
temps elle marche elle mâche quoi de
tout des racines de manioc riz bananes
vertes les feuilles de cactus des
écailles de tortue
quand elles sont bien moins rouillé est
tout seul le crash
dans une grande bassine on laisse
fermenter on appelle ça de la ccia
j'en bois moi tous les jours la barre à
célébrer sauvage pour la fête de la
pleine lune le mari y invite ses amis à
venir battre sa femme
c'est demain après lui
alors j'aurai peut-être pas le temps on
va envoyer les invitations envoyées et
bien tant pis je te battrais seul mais
plus longtemps la jeunesse bottes ses
fins elle se défendent pas non parce que
c est défendre leur coupe les oreilles
basses et on me coupait les hommes et il
y en a qui les arrache mais c'est pas
net tandis que moi je les connais et ils
à leur mauvaise humeur
ils ont l'air de ne pas nous en
apercevions il faut essayer de la base
où et si nous flattons sa vanité ans
ensemble en nous intéresser à ces
aventures
qu'est ce qu'on risque mon père
m'emmenait vous avez dû avoir des
aventures passionnantes là bas chez scea
diarra compte
j'adore d'écouter parler et m'a surtout
appris à couper les têtes proprement et
pourquoi les coupes style pour les
réduire au dieu ça choquant je voudrais
que la maman n'était pas du tout c'est
leur distraction favorite
oui ça se doit d'être follement amusant
follement là bas c'est simple on a un
ennemi on le tue parmi ces taux naturel
et on lui coupe la tête cela va de soi
oui comme ça on est sûr qu'il est
vraiment man and on n'est pas sûr qu'il
est vraiment mort parce qu'il reste
encore des choses dans sa tête et quad
dont sa volonté sa méchanceté les
esprits malfaisants qui ont pu s'y loger
alors on fait réduire la tête
rien n'est fait c'est une bonne
régression comment j pour un temps q ha
bah oui montre nous ton armé je ne me
touchez pas arrêté et vous je vous la
coupe pour de bon à la première chose
très important pour découper très large
voyez hauteur des épaules ou avoir de la
marge pour coudre de toute façon comme
on jette le reste
alors ensuite quand elle est coupée on
tape dessus avec une grosse pierre pour
faire tomber tout ce qu'il ya dedans et
pour nettoyer l'intérieur on retrouve
sous la peau
comme ça comme un corps louf louf lee
chin oui il parle de retourner une tête
comme si c'était la moindre élection
mais elle c'est la moindre des choses là
bas et le plus difficile quand on a
remis la peau à l'endroit cd recoudre
les yeux et la bouche c'est parce qu'il
faut un bar il traverse les lèvres avec
une grande et fine dallerès qui les ont
entourés d'une feuille d'eucalyptus ou
que ce soit bien et en jeu d'appeler sa
mère
oui tandis qu'avec moi c'est
pratiquement de la chirurgie esthétique
parce que moi je fais pas comme eux j'ai
cartellaire voyez j'écarte les loyers
j'étouffe actes et pas comme ça avant
j'écarte les lèvres vous voyez et je
recoupe à l'intérieur avec une grande
aiguille courbe dans c'est fini je tire
sur le film
elle se referme tout seul elle a
toujours été un artiste et maintenant
comment vas tu faire pour la rendre tout
petit
alors pour commencer je la fais bouillir
à gros bouillons mais non monsieur padro
bouillon sauvage
un petit feu je la pique de temps en
temps on voir si elle bien cuites
quand elle est à point je la sors je les
gouttes je les retourne et je la remplis
de sable chaud mon légionnaire
sous la chaleur du savon la tête ce
racornie se racornir accord d'ici là
cornu et c'est fini c'est très
intéressant tu verras j'ai quelques
petites pertes c'est dans ma valise
temps frai cados du ve c'est gentil vous
êtes à doha où est on
je ne suis pas le mauvais bougre la
preuve c'est que je ne vous fais la
porte que demain matin
il pourrait encore couchés ici cette
nuit bon ben dis donc c'est pas tout ça
j'ai faim - volte-face à manger il tâche
que ce soit bon ainsi dans les oreilles
à a vu bon d'avoir une douche mais
daniel gillet dit
oui ce n'est pas la peine de s'abaisser
devant lui ça n'a rien donné
ici je suis si ça a donné jusqu'à demain
matin
la pensionnaire nous descendre en tous
au bureau et nous truc rond la
comptabilité
il faut lui faire sauter tout ce que
nous pourrons encore la signature vous a
offert un gros chèque qu'armand ira
touché de mama thalla on peut mener tout
faire bon j'y pense
après le déjeuner on va descendre tous
ensemble au bureau pour vérifier la
comptabilité
parce que je vous connais on ne se
couchera que quand tout sera bien
claires et que d'ici là personne ne
bouge sans ma permission
c'est non ici il était lui mais c'est
une idée ça ait had a hi hop jay produit
tout ce que j'ai voulu dire
alors nous personne n'est au courant du
retour de daniel oui il avoué lui-même
n'y crois pas s'il disparaissait cette
nuit qui s'en inquièterait il resterait
mort car légalement il m'a c'est la loi
dit qu'il est mort elle a ses raisons
mais on ne peut pas se dresser contre
l'emploi si on se dresse contre la loi
c'est l'anarchie
oui mais le corps c'est mon plan oh on
pourrait peut-être le faire bouillir
pape à gros bouillons 1,6 viendrait tout
petit si quelqu'un d'autre comme ça je
vous lis à l'ancien puits qui est dans
le hangar
celui qu'on a fermé avec des plans elles
sont complètement pourri ses plans j'ai
toujours pensé qu'il arrive un accident
pendant l'échangé
après la difficulté c'est de faire
passer dessus puisqu'il veut vérifier
les côtes n'avons qu'à descendre avec
lui au chantier à sa droite un sa gauche
on le fait passer au bon endroit et
plouf 2010 décidément il est écrit qu'il
mourrait noyer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qu'est ce que les cheveux dix mois menée
par simon télégramme
si nous l'avons reçue hier matin est bon
alors je ne comprends pas votre surprise
maintenant je vais vous dire une bonne
chose laviolette wariner mais comme je
vous l'annonçais par celui de bogota qui
atterrit pas vrai savon telegraph il n'y
avait pas de daniel bernard sur la liste
des passagers
ah mais c'est que je ne m'appelle plus
daniel bernard mais ricardo fernandez
depuis quand depuis six ans henin on
aurait retrouvé
vous allez pas nous faire croire que
vous vivez là bas volontairement depuis
six ans sous une fausse identité
réfléchissez deux secondes j'étais
vivant je ne veux pas qu'on le sache je
change de nom et pourquoi aurait-il fait
une chose pareille aux pour coiffer de
l'histoire ancienne
donnons nous en l'actualité est le fait
du jour c'est que je suis là et comment
tu veux être là à vous vous êtes noyer
ben vous voyez bien que nous ne
commençons par un viêt noyer déjà venir
vous auriez vous noyer nous avons lu les
rapports sont formels
alors daniel daniel tu dois comprendre
dans quel état nous abat je m'en
aperçois te voir là après six ans de
silence alors qu'on croyait mort et
entendons nous dire que tu resté
volontairement caché comme c'était tout
naturel
difficile à avaler eh ben c'est pourtant
la stricte vérité je joue maintenant
nada obstine pas absurde il est une
autre raison
pourquoi ici j'ai été malade aux
incapables de donner tes nouvelles
tu as perdu la mémoire mais pas du tout
assure que je me porte très bien et que
ma mémoire n'a jamais su que des
feuilles
alors quoi quoi que vous est-il arrivé
c'est pas si ça va vous amuser beaucoup
mais enfin puisque vous y tenez traoui
alors ça y est vous parce que pour vous
compreniez bien il faut que
je reprenne mes commencement alors ça
nous ramène au 18 janvier 1973 c'est le
jour de l'accident
voilà le matin nous avions établi notre
camp sur la rive gauche du mara nous
avec le professeur martinod une
clairière super d'ailleurs qui est
descendant en pente douce vers le fleuve
les perroquets bavards des dents les
hibiscus ajoute en prime vous perdez pas
dans les détails vingt deux jeunes
enfants alors je lui ai proposé
d'explorer à l'afflux en proche sur les
rives duquel je pensais trouver des
tarahumaras descoings d'etarras oumara
c'est une tribu indienne latéraux pas
tout le temps alors vous ne savez pas ce
qui m'a répondu le professeur martin
il m'a répondu vous avez raison c'est
par là qu'il faut commencer et alors
alors rien mais ça m'a fait plaisir
d'autant plus qu'il a ajouté je n'en
garde pas de nous avoir emmenés je suis
sûr que nous allons faire du bon travail
ensemble
c'est vrai vous avez des qualités de
rodas d'initiatives qui font les grands
explorateurs
en effet quelle mémoire rappelle sa joie
pour l'oublier venant du professeur
martin on savait du prix c'est que c'est
quelqu'un martineau ben il en était à sa
sixième expédition lui ces ouvrages sur
les civilisation inca font autorité
c'est un esprit et minorent oui ça nous
n'en doutons pas mais enfin tu pourrais
passer directement
alors je lui ai répondu qu'il exagérait
peut-être un peu mais mérite même pas du
tout même mais il s'est presque fâché
mais m'a dit mais non mais vous êtes
trop modeste vous avez l'esprit
scientifique de l'initiative
vous êtes un grand sportif kayakistes
hors ligne j'ai rarement vu autant de
qualités réunies chez un seul homme
c'est vraiment très aimable merveilleux
d'autant qu'il a conclu vous allez
mettre non seulement utile mais
indispensable
alors j'ai pris mon kayak suivi de nos 2
ghz indien dans leurs pirogues et vers
midi nous le sommes arrêtés sur les bord
du gouffre dont vous avez entendu parler
à nous y arrivons nous y sommes alors
pour commencer on a détruit le kayak
quoi quoi la wii sa hausse a même été le
plus difficile entre parenthèses xavier
a raison 1,5 épaisseur ce bien suffisant
alors j'ai fait cadeau d'une grande
vente de tissus rouges et vertes
tu es les indiens et puis deux
bouteilles de whisky pour qu'ils disent
partout qu'il m'avait vu me noyer et je
suis parti voilà qu'est ce que ça te dit
qu'est ce que c'est que cette histoire
jalonnée que rift martin on vient te
dire que tu était indispensable d'aller
tous fiers et contents en conclusion
vous le planter là vous détruisez le
gallia que vous partez dans la forêt
vierge un pied à pied comment voulez
vous que je parte autrement
ce n'est pas normal vous avez une
association le coup de bambou les
fièvres nom de ce produit dans mon
existence un événement capital quel
événement voilà rappelez-vous ici quand
je voulais donner mon avis sur quelque
chose ça n'intéresse généralement
personne sans doute parce que je n'étais
pas intéressé au mieux ce qu'on appelle
certainement alors imaginez ma surprise
quand je me suis rendu compte que le
professeur martinod me laisser parler
lui qui m'écoutait sans l'interrompre
lui qui est le problème du plaisir à
montendre lui à parce qu'ici on vous
laissez pas parler on écoute est plus
que jamais mais jamais nous entende et
vaguement les premiers mots comme ça à
partir de ce moment-là vous n'écoutez
plus vous cherchez comment vous allez
pouvoir dire le contraire
et dans la plupart des pas vous est
réussie c'est très bien et après vous
nous avons l'esprit de contradiction
mais absolument
tiens toi quand je voulais te faire
faire quelque chose je m'amusais à te
suggérer le contraire
eh ben tu prenais immédiatement le
contre-pied et j'avais gagné je ne
croyais pas si naïve mais comme vous le
prétendez pas nous faire croire que vous
avez pris une décision aussi extra la
gombe simplement parce qu'ici on n'était
pas toujours de votre avis centrale ou
frac
mais je vous ai prévenus c'est très
rigolo mais là alors ça m'a éclaté dans
la tête c'est quand martin on m'a dit
qu'il me tenait en haute estime et qu'il
appréciait beaucoup mon intelligence
parce que nous n'apprécions pas ton
intelligence tu sais bien ce que j étais
dans cette maison non mais tu étais le
direct alors le direct
or le directeur oui mais en fait je t'ai
rien chaque fois qu'il ya une décision à
prendre
satwa qu'on s'adressait 1 à qui la faute
vous l'aviez aucune autorité mais avant
tout le monde j'avais l'air d'un petit
garçon quand tu étais là dès que
j'ouvrais la bouche pour parler de me
regardait avec un air tellement navré si
j'allais dire une incongruité que
forcément moi je me troublait je
bafouille est de sorte qu'on tue des
gens j'avais l'air d'un père frère
crétin c'est toi qui imaginaient déjà
bien complexe voilà et c'est très
inconfortable
un complexe ça vous coupe tous vos
moyens je vous ai plus parlé moi à
chaque fois que j'avais une idée
j'étais tellement sûr vous alliez à
trouver stupide que je la gardais pour
moi et peu à peu j'étais arrivé a pu en
avoir du tout voyez vous que c'est drôle
c'est irrésistible et nous sont revenus
comme ça tout à coup aux idées
ça a été une illumination un jour je
suis voilà ou bien tu rentres à nogent
sur mana après l'expédition et alors là
dans 10 ans étant complètement abruti ou
bien tu fais le plongeon et l'avenir est
à toi
le plongeon que le plongeon après le
plongeon l'expression péruvienne tous
les jours les journaux on lit qu'à
monsieur a disparu sur un gros sache ni
pourquoi ni comment là bas il appelle ça
faire le plongeon ce que j'ai fait
pendant l'arrivée après fait directement
dans ma nature
un petit trou dans les broussailles qui
s'est refermée derrière moi et c'était
fini daniel bernard était mort mais moi
j'étais sauvé détendu léger décomplexée
si vous savez ce que c'est bon
eh ben mon vieux
déjà vu les difficultés mais alors là
vous êtes un voyou votre cynisme et
révoltant louis rivol annoncé comique
pour un bien
tel doit être fier en le plongeant faits
tels que je te connais tu n'as pas dû
être long à le regretter
vous tous et n'oubliez les sauvages
courageux comme vous êtes ça n'a pas dû
être drôle tous les jours
oh non je t'ai pas à plaindre même quand
je me suis retrouvé en prison à lima
afin de raconter mon histoire aux
policiers chargés de monter au rejet ça
lui a tellement plu qu'il a insisté pour
me faire des faux papiers
je me demande bien ce qui a pu lui
plaire à la similitude de nos deux cas
parce que lui aussi il avait fait
plongeon alors il m'a emmené à son club
son club le club des amis des plongeurs
tu es là bas que les citoyens de lima se
réunissent pas tout ce qu'ils ont fait
comme moi qui sont partis sans laisser d
adresse jolie société ils ont un club et
ils sont au nombre de 150 environ venus
de tous les coins du monde
ce club a été fondé pour permettre aux
plongeurs qui émergent et leur faciliter
leur réintégration dans leur nouvelle
vie a heureusement parce que tout ça du
temps s'est jamais sorti y a qu'à penser
à ce que serait devenue la faire de
votre père si nous n'avions pas été là
pour faire de la chance qu'ils soient
nés avant toi depuis votre départ et la
marche est aussi bien que lorsque vous
étiez rares oui presque mieux garantie
est une fille qui est très bien bonne
bordée de maintenant ça suffit un beau
si je vous dis ce que je pense
si vous le prenez sur stoner parce que
jusqu'à maintenant je voulais enveloppé
dans du papier de soie
maintenant c'est terminé quand je pars
en on coupe la parole
alors je vous disais depuis six ans je
n'ai pas perdu mon temps moi aussi j'ai
fait mes preuves et j'ai pas mal de
nouveau à vous apprendre nous aussi
figure toi est ce que vous y voyez
peut-être qu'ici ne s'était rien passé
au nom aux lots non non parce qu'avant
de partir j'étais abonnée à une agence
de renseignement justement pour me tenir
au courant de ce qui se passera ici
c'est par elle que j'ai appris des
fiançailles d'ailleurs tu as un prix
méfiance on est elle vous a rien fait
aussi ça m'a fait de la peine a même
rarement
ah bah oui je me suis dit voilà un
garçon sensible comme moi influençable
elle vaut lui [ __ ] le complexe et ben
je m'étais pas trompé il est foutu fou
tu commences à ce foutu mais oui vous
êtes foutus coûteux pris de laisser un
ventre n'est pas ne lui répondait pas
nous sommes là pour vous défendre parce
qu'il peut même plus défendre tout seul
mais des deux ans encore plus grave que
je pensais mais plus droit à la parole
comment j'ai pu moi la parole je vais
vous dire une bonne chose
elle voyait on vous laisse même pu finir
vos phrases à vous non plus je vais vous
dire quand je veux finir mes phrases ces
rencontres nous enseignons aux frais
tomates et non maintenant je ne sais
plus j'ai quelque chose à dire je le dis
jusqu'au bout et d'hommes et c'est comme
on veut
vous en êtes au fond où j'en étais quand
je suis parti vous serez bientôt aussi
amorphe que julien bon je vous défends
tu insultes et mon mari je suis à bord
est quelqu'un de bien julien quand il a
connu marti sorte est centrale et
regarder ce qu'on a fait gauche à ses
décors en faux prix de sortir monsieur
le sortir décès chez moi vous plaisantez
gardez le pour vieux et peut même pu
aligner deux idées la suite l'une de
l'autre
dès qu'il va parler tellement pris
l'habitude de ne pas aller jusqu'au bout
qui réfléchit même plus à ce qu'il va
dire si vous ne sortez pas si moi qui
vais sortie mais c'est vous qui lui dit
qu'il ouvre la bouche que produire des
bêtises
alors à force de le lui répéter c'est
devenu vrai lui on a mis trente ans à la
mer cet état là vous ce sera moins long
parce que leur technique s'est
perfectionnée moi vous voyez bien qu'ils
essaient vous démoraliser
celui-ci à mort que ça mais c'est tout
ce qu'il trouve votre ménard jalouse de
notre bonheur mais moi je le tue crainte
des finales qui remplace avantageusement
à ça et certains qui doit vous donner
beaucoup plus de satisfaction que moi
parce que dans l'état où vous l'avez mis
peu plus vous porter ombrage
ça suffit 1 je vais pas jouer ou casser
la figure à main n'ont même pas du tout
mais ya six ans vous m'auriez casser la
figure
et je ne me serais pas frotter mais
maintenant mon pauvre
non mais vous dites ça parce que vous le
voyez tous les jours vous rendez pas
compte de changement mais moi qui l'ait
pas vu depuis six ans mais je suis
effrayé garder ça il lui reste à peu
près autant de combativité qui a une
image non mêlant chez moi non mais
lâchez moi
lâchez moi vous savez si au moins ce
n'est pas pareil il ya six ans il aurait
dit le quart ou non il répondu des
choses cinglante
parce que vous étiez vif vous aviez l
esprit de répartie maintenant vous êtes
complètement ramolli mon bon vieux mais
un courrier vous laissez pas insulter
voyons m'excuser qui me répond dilapide
réflexe j'ai bien entendu
tiens il ya six ans quand on jouait au
que deux mots c'est toujours lui qui
gagnait aujourd'hui je suis sûr sera
incapable de trouver trois roues est ce
que vous allez chercher là maintenant
les que deux mots ce ridicule qui était
bon il ya longtemps voulait jouer plus
difficile à bavarder ce qu'il faut de la
vivacité d'esprit
voulez vous pariez que je vous bat plate
couture à libé brésil à les bigarreaux
1-0 bigard au billard au billard au
robinet de 1,0 robinet
mais ce qu'on vous demande quelque chose
robinet d'eau chaude taisez vous êtes
hors concours d'avoir robinet 3 0 vous
avez raison il trouve plus rien vous
allez tomber vous mais c'est pas le
temps alors mesurer votre perte de
vitesse nénuphars 1a les nénuphars
nénuphars pharmacie 4 à 0 j'allais dire
à mme hasina oui la semaine prochaine sa
tombe durant dans votre petite tête hein
c'est comme dans la chanson
on va évidemment pas de lui dire ça
finit par le croire et sa part ali m
mais c'est le résultat de notre fameuse
méthode est très efficace
audriel à faire breveter pharmacie
attendez attendez j'attends
parapharmacie si comme un sac à 0,6
commun comment vont ils mort-aux-rats
sets à zéro mort aux rats cadets temps
déjà que d'une règle de rein que de beau
je tiens mes doigts de sa toit noir à 0
7 à 0 à dire oui encore à moi je vous
dis pourquoi tiens je voulais en venir
aux mains des rebelles mais j'ai
commencé par là quand je suivais ici
seulement moi je me suis évadé rosanna
elle joue pas rose anna ne souffle pas
tu vas te faire tremper dans un ananas 9
à 0 bravo toutes les deux mais copé -
vous avez fait du bon travail
il a le cerveau en gelée
ça tremble autres lap dance tout ça peut
faire un ananas l'année répond quelque
chose non celle entrevue - oui allez un
petit effort ananas à ce degré à sa
trêve ah non mais ça compte pas que nous
on souffle et non au nom de ma mère je
veux dire c'est que c'est pas génial
tpiy et moi j'ai 10 ans et de 13 ans et
romain vous avez triché
oui tu as triché c'est très chiant ça je
le sentais venir
je sentais qu'on allait finir par se
dire des choses désagréables mais croyez
bien que j'en suis profondément désolé
mais qu'est ce que vous faites c'était
tellement insisté pour que je vous
explique
merci pour l'explication ça n'excuse pas
notre conduite
il faut être vraiment ce que vous avez
ici sur mariés sont nombreux nara mort
et je n'avais pas l'empêcher de refaire
sa vie
j'ai bien fait la mienne vous aussi vous
êtes remarquer non c'est à dire que je
me suis refait une situation dans les
kayaks
naturellement j'ai commencé par un
construire un qui a eu un gros succès
parce qu'ils connaissaient pas les
théières clients si bien que là bas
maintenant je suis à la tête du plus
grand chantier naval d'el callao
seulement la sphère après une telle
importance qu'il est impossible de
continuer à diriger sous une fausse
identité parce que tu vas voir des
marchés importants à traiter avec la
marine nationale péruvienne alors c'est
plus possible
il devient urgent que je reprenne mon
nom c'est d'ailleurs le seul motif de
mon retour
3 peignoir déjà à faire avant tout le
reste à nos noms mais ne croyez pas ça
ou mais je me rend très bien compte que
ma rentrée si je la sirène dans une
situation insupportable
oui c'est bien simple et les big un nom
mais très provisoirement savez je ne
veux vous causer aucun souci d'ailleurs
mon divorce avec irene va remettre les
choses en ordre
votre divorce écoutez vous avez l'air
d'oublier la situation d'hier est pas du
tout pas du tout je sais très bien ce
qu'elle a fait ce que je peux vous que
vous avez tous vais pour cette maison
d'ailleurs maintenant je considère que
cette affaire est à vous au nom tout de
même tu ne va pas le contredire toi tu
sais bien qu'il ne supporte pas ça au
plus maintenant je suis vacciné en alors
après quand tout sera réglé je m'en vais
et vous n'aurez que le désagrément de me
revoir quelques fois pendant les
formalités parce que je me suis
renseigné aimerait quand même pour deux
mois
en ce qui concerne le divorce de le dire
ni ne pourra pas avoir lieu secrètement
tout le monde est au courant de votre
retour ici les journalistes vont affluer
alors qu'est ce qu'on va leur dire la
vérité à ce serait flatteur sourire on
s'est tu crois que ça l'inquiète
on trouvera bien l'explication qui sauve
les apparences alors après vous vous
mariez tous les deux un
et moi je disparais et si ça peut vous
être agréable
vous ne me reverrez plus jamais oui que
tout ça n'est pas bien dramatique
en effet c'est une simple formalité et
couture elle qu'on ne nous racontons pas
d'histoires un tu as très bien vécu sans
bras pendant six ans du terme ariès tout
à fait naturel moi je vais pas le faire
parce que j'ai pas eu l'occasion mais ne
me dis pas que le fait que je sois en
vie va bouleverser son existence au même
si je te le disais qu'est ce que ça
pourrait le faire
je tenais pas à inquiéter toi quand tu
as fait cette chose inconcevable
comment tu étais pas soucié de ma
douleur de mes angoisses pendant des
nuits je me suis réveillé la nuit en
criant parce que je voyais dans mes
cauchemars en train de noyer matos pour
jerry maman se demandait si des gens à
la porte et votre deuil et on peut dire
qu'il a été très bien je suis désolé il
est bien temps ben qu'est ce que tu veux
moi je savais que je t'ai landry alors
je prenais pas ma mort tragique
et d'autre part je pensais pas qu'elle
allait te frapper à ce point là parce
que tu ne savais pas que je t'aime et tu
croyais que je t'avais épousé la cause
de ta situation et run c'était un
mariage d'amour oui et celui avec armand
aussi parce qu'ils n'avaient rien non
plus à tuer parfait toi tu l'a oublié
toi notre soirée dans la grange pendant
cet orage non on disait qu'on était des
enfants perdus dont je vais être très
malheureux oui c'est même pas qui jouera
le mieux d'ailleurs
l'ati c'est qu'entre moi avec un air si
misérable que j'en avais les larmes aux
yeux
si moi qui tu es obligé de te consoler
tu te souviens de ce que tu m'as dit moi
je ne vais jamais oublier tu m'as dit si
j'étais malheureux toute ma vie et que
j'étais près de moi pour me consoler
comme je serai heureux oui je me
rappelle et moi et moi j'étais répondu
dix minutes comme celle là ne se vivent
pas deux fois
c'était vrai tu sais qui n'ait jamais
connu de pareils bons numéros et je vais
mais je me je me permets de vous
rappeler que je suis là et alors là
aussi on a eu des moments
10h10
cette nuit encore tu me disais je t'en
supplie ne soit pas mu par dessus le
marché commence à voir le marché que
j'ai fait moi sylvie qu'est ce qu'on vit
comme un musée
ouais mais personne ne vous reproche
rien il est un peu nerveux tout à fait
compréhensible mais je ne veux pas être
une cause de disputes
alors si vous le permettez je m'en vais
je vais rentrer chez moi ça vaudra mieux
comment rentrer au pérou à pied un stuff
and a quand je suis rentré chez moi
toute façon de parler
on s'est fait un appartement au rythme
au début l'idée vous avez là tu avais la
peur c'est un jeune homme trouve que
c'est une bonne idée quand le rythme
pour passer inaperçu pour que les
scandales éclatent avant que nous ayons
eu le temps d'inventer une histoire
plausible mais attention mon ami le
gâtisme de guerre il ya peu de chances
pour que je rencontre quelqu'un qui me
reconnaissent parce qu'au bout de six
ans même dû beaucoup changer de bord
vous avez vu comme tout le monde
décidément ce soir tu te surpasse
tu n'as pas du tout changé je trouve
cela non plus d'ailleurs j'ai
l'impression d'avoir quitté avant-hier
non mais ça va pas un robot je suis mais
je suis demandé un taxi à poil et aux
vitz en tout cas écouter n'importe où
j'irai je risque de rencontrer quelqu'un
on apporte ses breaks
1 sauf ici ici wafa ma présence était
désagréable à ce point non non pas du
tout au contraire
non mais on avait je peux aller coucher
ailleurs si je dérange d'abord j'ai pas
vu puisque vous le faites remarquer sur
est en effet plus convenable de vous
éloigner le soir surtout tant que les
choses ne sont pas officiellement remise
en argent vous dites là même un toit aux
yeux de la loi comme à ceux technique
d'ailleurs le seul mari d'irene c'est
daniel un mari qui est ne tient
nullement à faire valoir ses droits quel
droit mais quel ton art est temps que
mon mariage n'est pas annulée je suis
encore le mari d'irene manon et non pas
d'arcus il faut vous éloigner les
convenances excellent en gt1 monde sa
fille sourit comme un [ __ ] et les
convenances exige que ce soit moi qui
ait aussi rieur et ben merde alors au
retour il faut reconnaître que c'est
plutôt c'est plutôt drôle
c'est une situation curieuse façon
lemoine ans mais très provisoire cela
faire de quelques semaines deux mois ou
plus mais en mettant tout au mieux
pendant nom se dit sidéré hoping to play
n'a pas d'autre solution
oui l'ennui c'est que mes bagages sont
déjà au rythme je vais aller le chercher
pour te faire remarquer non armand pas
ce que je ferais ses courses en plus non
mais vous rêvez vous m'avez talent et
vous écoutez je préfère encore aller
faire un tour dehors parce qu'au départ
on ne me connaît pas sauf que tout
casser et qu'ils voient
[Applaudissements]
mettez-vous à sa place oui c'est
justement ça qui m'énerve
soyez tranquilles ils se calmera il ira
chercher vos bagages
quel est il
7h50 julien en attendant le dîner
tu devrais conduire daniel au chantier
pour qu'il voie les transformations en
vallouise au ou daniel oui on ira aussi
jusqu'au vieux pont 1 comme on faisait
autrefois après le travail
très bonne idée la bonne idée allons-y
frais à ça ça va revenir
elle vieux pondre ça aussi c'est un
souvenir
oui quand j'étais petit c'est là que mon
papa m'apprenait à plonger dans l'eau
dans l'eau mais pourquoi dit il ça
j'étais pas du tout ma pauvre chéri
quelle épreuve ah oui alors ça a comme
je pense qu'il est tout à leur évoqué
devant lui il faut première rencontre je
te sentais si amusant avait mal pour toi
un ami si tu sais j'ai bien regardé
l'été tour mais oui je l'espère bien
je conçois tout ce que cette situation
pénible mais dans deux mois il ne sera
plus là et de moi c'est vite passé deux
mois parce que tu t'imagines que je vais
laisser repartir ça par exemple pour
qu'il retourne là bas qu'elle soit le
seul maître de son affaire d'el callao
et qu'ils nous imposent toutes ces
conditions ici parce que c'est très bas
âge dans l'ensemble ce qui nous a dit
qu'il me humilié comme ils la font et
qu'il gagne la partie sur toute la ligne
non j'aime mieux être mort est une
merveilleuse avant ces circonstances la
pensée à la sphère d'amérique garder la
tête froide à ce point là vu que je te
dise c'est subi bon c'est pas par
intérêt ça je te le jure je devrai bien
tout ce que j'ai pour rabattre son
insolence à à elle a besoin de moi il a
réussi sans y croyais pouvoir me rayer
comme ça d'un seul coup au le plongeon
mais je vais lui remettre la tête sous
l'eau moi j'ai deux mois pour y arriver
c'est plus qu'il n'en faut à jeter
tyrannie qu'il pouvait pas supporter ça
eh bien il ne supportera était rien eh
bien il sera encore moins
je veux le voir dans cette pièce à
quatre pattes se traîner me manger dans
la main comme un caniche bravo et compte
sur moi pour t d un homme qui est mort
pendant six ans il mérite qu'on apprenne
à vivre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un gars qu'ils ne voulaient entendre sur
mon phone haut que deux morceaux le
concerto brandebourgeois ou la marche du
6e doivent à tout prix c'est sûr je vais
essayer de lui faire écouter le titre
j'ai fini je finis d'ailleurs déroule
d'ailleurs que je traîne devant le coeur
des monts la viande et à 11h20 bien et
tout le temps ici à wassit dans la
poubelle minutes qui me tient alors mais
font qu' il faut que je me prépare
et puis s'agirait pas que je le rate
l'avion parce que des doors santos et
commence à se faire du mauvais sang là
bas rhin si vous l'aviez entendu et au
bout du fil
parce que c'était net mais un récit m'a
dit ici les fans des découvertes
décennale fernandez lui avait donné des
instructions pour deux mois d'absence ça
fait trois mois que je suis ici alors il
s'en sort plus efficace elle doit coûter
très cher ses coups de téléphone un
surtout en espagnol oui on bat de toutes
façons je suis ça coûte une fortune
c'est bien simple encore quelques mois
de ce régime et j'étais complètement
vinet enfin maintenant heureusement tout
est réglé tout est agréé vous trouvez
jugement de divorce n'interviendra pas
avant deux mois et votre absence risque
de le faire envoyer là-bas au contraire
ce sera une charge de plus contre moi ça
facilitera la tâche de ton avocat alors
tout est pour le mieux nous donner voir
si l'on peut dire oui
la fable du retour et de l'apesi de
daniel avait été admise les gens
croyaient qu'il était rentré
définitivement leur part alors comment
allons nous expliquer ça pouvait nous
n'avons pas envoyé de fer pas mêlant
puis je pars le pen quand on verra car
mans revient avec nous il y aura pas
besoin d'explications tout le monde
comprendra très bien oui mais comme il
par vagues à n'importe quoi ça revient
au même
oui mais de toute façon vous savez il
faut pas il faut pas exagérer le
retentissement de mon départ parce que
dans quelques jours personne n'y pensons
plus rien ne sera comme ici mon retour
ne sera plus qu'un mauvais souvenir
c'est pas très gentil ce que tu dis là
bon je te demande en leur nom je voulais
pas de blessé je possède trois mois
merveilleux ici
et toi aussi j'espère
seulement il faut qu'il aille parce que
pour laisser des souvenirs il faut s'en
aller c'est profond ça non
je comprends ta vie à ce qu'il veut dire
il veut dire que s'ils partaient pas
mais alors ça ne change rien oui
d'accord écouter tu allais me mabille et
je crois que ça vaudra mieux oui oui je
vous accompagne à l'aéroport les faire
arriver un accident non armand
l'emmènera monsieur peu en retard et
c'est parce que je suis parti rue jean
toujours prendre le plan du salon me
sens pas mal
à oui voyons ça parce que il faut
débarrasser la table
voilà avaler dedans la silhouette au
danger la passion attention voyons
pouvait renverser le lait va poser sur
la ba oui oui tout de suite irène
il me semble que c'est un peu moi
plagiat placé que l'année dernière il
n'y a pas de raison il faut exiger non
c'est parfait nous sommes juste à gauche
de l'entrée principale
nous serons les premiers que les
visiteurs verront oui s'ils prennent à
gauche en entrant messier prennent à
droite on sera les derniers évidemment
pas être des deux côtés avant à paris du
mois parce que peut-être qu'au pérou je
crois qu'on vous met en boîte l'arrêtant
vous savez c'est pas grave c'est le
moment d'en profiter parce qu'il n'y a
plus pour longtemps et l'eau et non
c'est fou comme le temps passe vite et
enfin il parle pas pour moi oui bien sûr
en tout cas je voulais vous dire que
j'ai été très sensible à votre
délicatesse savais pas du tout c'est la
moindre des choses si l'état a été très
pénible pour moi bien sûr c'est déjà
faire deux kilomètres de joinville aussi
quelle idée d'aller prendre une chambre
à joinville-le-pont oui alors qu'ils
avaient l'hôtel du grand cerf de temps
chypre et ce n'est pas la peine non si
sa mort était trop dure écrit le disque
à la pomme d'api mais quand même un tout
seul à l'hôtel ça lui est bien triste
quand même nom les tg très gai là bas
c'est très très gay s'est essayée pour
les autres pas pour moi parce que
j'avais j'avais des voisins très
agréable à monsieur il n'était jamais là
sauf le samedi venu voir sa femme elle
était charmant à eau pour elle non plus
été payés à la rue là là tous les gens
qui s'ennuient ben oui comme des indiens
et on va voir s'il y atteler sans
travail sûr tu va conduire daniela voici
tout et on parie sur des matchs est bon
des documents je m'habille pour le
voyage je mets mon
mon pull over leconte et gris tu dois
savoir mieux non non je crois que je
vais mettre le pull-over alors oui et tu
crèveras de chaud dans l'avion vous avez
accepté surchauffée non c'est climatisé
mais quand même vous avez raison non le
jeu est le couple est gris alors oui
pour crever de froid en arrivant je
croyais que c'était l'hiver bon ben j'ai
besoin de mon pull over alors un jeu
mettra sur mon bras et tu perdras non
non je fais attention je leur filerais
redescendre je vais m'habiller ce jour
nous a manqué que joue tu l'as entendu
te demander comment il pouvait
s'habiller
abb annonce teddy deux jours de plus il
restait pour être pire rappelle toi nous
en étions il ya à peine un mois
majoritaire daniel majoritaire avec 51%
des parts autant dire qu'il était le
maître ne voulait même pas me donner un
pouvoir pour les simples opérations
bancaires j'ai mis huit jours et
l'obtenir mais c'est un pouvoir général
qu'il aurait fallu lui arracher je lai
non quand l'at il signé cette nuit c'est
déjà mieux mais ça n'en est que plus
navrant quelques jours de plus et il
reprenait en bas mais autant dire nous
sommes les maîtres de la faire je peux
même tout vendre sans nous prévenir
c'est pas mal ce nom c'est pas mal à
condition qu ils ne dénoncent pas ce
pouvoir y donnera toujours le droit prof
manière n'est pas capable de ça il est
capable de tout c'est comme pour la
faire l'amérique tu l'as entendu il
parle de l'associer dans une certaine
mesure avec celle d'ici messages sur des
promesses en l'air qui change d'avis et
l'a fait en amérique nous passe sous le
nez alors que s'il était resté et tous
les espoirs étaient permis
ah oui mais je ne suis pas arrivé c'est
pourtant pas faute d'avoir essayé
or je peux pas le croire tous avaient
tous les atouts en main on avait noyé
armand tu t'es seul avec lui
mais pas en boîte j'ai même cru plus
d'une fois que je l'avais repris
totalement tient la nuit dernier encore
me donner dans ses bras je me sers est
si fort j'ai senti qu'il faiblisse et si
brusquement il s'est mis à rire quelques
histoires idiotes
il aura traversé la tête de tettey ce
qu'est ce que tu dis tu t'étais sang
royal
ça y est je le sentais venir quoi mais
ma pauvre enfant je vous observe daniel
et toi depuis quelques jours sur tout
mais vous eûtes et touchant d'aurélie de
jeunes mariés qu'est ce que tu racontes
tu vas pas t'imaginer que je suis
amoureuse de lui non ce serait énorme
énorme ou pas il faut de rendre à
l'évidence tu vois pas dans quel état tu
es si je suis malade de rage
enfin si c'était que çà et là c'est
beaucoup plus grave et si tu ne te rends
pas compte maintenant tu vas pas quand
il sera parti dans deux heures car enfin
dans deux heures il sera parti mais tant
mieux on n'entendra plus parler des
jeunes etc c'est ça c'est ça insiste
bien mon dieu c'est une catastrophe les
beaux jours sont bien finies désormais
cette maison sera un enfer contraire on
sont bien tranquilles
or sont bien tranquilles je te connais
la courageuse comme que tu vas prendre
sur toi devra serrer les dents tu vas
faire bon visage armand et la nuit je
tendrais sangloter pas pour moi aussi ce
sera un calvaire
non je ne pleure jamais tu pleures
jamais regardé mois à les regarder en
face de cire pas les dents je te connais
pas je vois bien tu vas est relaté en
sanglots au olemps toile images qui
illustrent les sept soulagement
c'est dans ces moments là c'est tout ce
qui nous reste nous autre femme les
larmes femme avait deux filles je te
comprends que je te comprends il te
restera toujours ta maman tu sais où
c'est plus fort que pleure pleure ne
tient pas non je ne veux pas qu'il nous
voit pleurer c'est ça pour qu'il parte
la conscience tranquille ah non pardon
ce serait trop commode
daniel daniel
si l'heure mais pleure donc pour moi
c'est notre dernière chance
mais qu'est-ce qui se passe voilà votre
rêve
ça ne vous a pas suffit de faire le
malheur de ma fille une fois il faut que
vous larguiez plus malheureuse en quoi
et pourquoi pleures t-elle enfin j'avais
tout arrangé pour le mieux on va tout
arranger mais vous avez donc une pierre
à la place du coeur et vous restez la
fois ça vous aimez bien les verts de la
voie soufie retenez moi j'aime bien m'en
aller parce que je vous dirais des mots
qui dépassent ma pensée
vous êtes un misérable ambitieux et je
ne pleure pas je t'en supplie je peux
pas supporter de voir pleurer
laisse moi mais que veux tu que je m'en
aille enfin je dois te laisser dans cet
état là je n'ai jamais vu comme ça
pendant que je t'en supplie ne me lève
pas tout mon courage quelle raison fait
raison il faut que sois forte
oui je veux pas te faire de la peine à
toi aussi je t'en ai fait autrefois sans
vouloir te demande pardon non non non
c'est moi qui te demande pardon
donc quand je suis parti il ya six ans
j'ai pensé car qu'à moi mais je voulais
pas faire de mal tu sais mais
aujourd'hui aussi ne pense qu'à toi tu
as ta vie là bas tu es heureux c'est
l'essentiel pour moi le bonheur c'est
mais non c'est pas fini la vie va
reprendre comme avant mon retour tutorat
le chantier ton travail mais aussi d'un
travail fait en arrivant là bas alors
d'ailleurs c'est ce qui nous permettra
de reprendre notre équilibre à l'homme
ne pensons qu'à ça au travail c'est
facile à dire sa toiture a peut-être
d'autres consolation que ce travail là
bas je te jure bien que non ya ptet pas
cyril torres va être jalouse
si messi mais je ne penserai que ça peut
imaginer dans les bras d'une autre femme
je ne pourrai pas tout j'étais loin de
supposées j'ai les oubliera toit toutes
ses nuits que nous avons passé non moi
je ne l'oublierai jamais je ne savais
plus ce que c'était que des mais en
réalité je n'ai jamais su qu avec toi
depuis six ans j'en avais perdu le
souvenir
des complets ya de l'essence il ya
tourisme à rabat je demande pardon je
veux juste prendre la voiture promet
dans la valise à jouer l'avion l'avion
de l'avion dans la voiture je reviendrai
tu vas partir
plus jamais je ne connaîtrais l'amour en
réalité tu ne seras revenu que pour m'en
rappeler la douce tu vas me laisser deux
fois non non non il faut que tu as pas
le droit de dire ça donne d'abord gaga
armand il me rappelle qu'il existe
tu peux penser causeur merveilleuse que
nous avons vécu ensemble
souviens toi de cette dernière nuit
j'aurais voulu qu'elle ne finisse jamais
moi aussi mes coups ne parle pas non pas
de ça parce que le l'heure du départ
approche et il faut il faut pas
s'attendre et on ne me demande pas
l'impossible toi tu es un homme tu as la
tête solide aussi tu va franchir cette
forte tu seras déjà loin tu vas prendre
l'avion
penser à ton affaire de la base ce sera
fini oh non trois parties je n'aurai
plus de courage plus d'ambition quand je
serai plus la même femme je le sens
cette maison sera trop lourd mais ne dit
pas ça un mythe ou tendance pour que la
sphère puisse marcher sans moi alors tu
vera vous allez faire une année
magnifique non non c'était si tu restais
que l'année serait m'a dit tu sais que
c'est pas possible on m'attend là bas
j'ai tout réglé pour que tu puisses je
me remplacer c'est bien je te l'aï signé
un pouvoir qui fait de toi l'unique
directrice de kayak bernard alors je
n'en veux plus comment leur pluton
pouvoir enfin y voir qu'est ce que tu
attends tu crois que tu m'as fait assez
mal comme ça c'est pour quoi faire
je peux pas partir je veux pouvoir
rester non plus mais se passe mais non
mais de toute façon ça aide la folie bon
l'avion par dans une heure et demie
alors j'ai déjà pris les décisions plus
grave plus été payés armand et armand
galy et m&m armand c est qu est ce qui
deviendrait lui serait un coup terrible
pour lui on ne me paraît pas d'armes ans
je serai capable de tuer
irène tu me fais peur personne ne
marchera toi tu sais maintenant ce que
c'est que d'être un homme devient pas
retenir mais tu ne sens pas que nous ne
faisons qu'un que rien ne peut nous
séparer si je crois que je pourrais être
quitter mais non c'est aussi je pourrais
croire
non
papa maman qu'est ce qui se passe et la
récente promotion coup sur coup moi pour
toi qu'est ce qu'est la pauvre maman
sénat sera jeudi six combattants de
reims la mongie enfants il faut que je
vous embrasse le support tant d'années
je respire et vous aussi j'en suis sûr
non mais regarde le ses plus beaux jours
de sa vie voilà là mais je peux pas je
peux pas j'ai pas à laisser santos tout
seul là bas ah non non ça c'est pas
parce que ce serait un désastre ça non
nous n'avions pas pensé à ça s'il doit
l'espérer ce miracle si seulement je te
laisse est quelqu'un de capable à el
kala otages suisses adjoindre à santos
mais vraiment pas alors là bas tu penses
1 et bia il n'y a qu'à chercher ici bas
comment ici pourquoi laissons le
réfléchir avec son esprit de décision je
suis sûr qu'il va trouver tout j'ai beau
réfléchir
je vois pas mais s'il ya bien quelqu'un
ici qui est au courant de tous que
daniel voit tous les jours et qui nous
est très dévoué armand beewi armand dire
que nous y pensions pas à
je crois que vous tenez là une idée qu
sensationnel à un homme l affaire est
très importante la base se passait il
aura les épaules l'autorité l'autorité
c'est l'autorité même demandé irait s'il
n'a pas la pression parce qu'il est très
renfermé mais il s'affirme quand il le
faut ma part toi même tu me disais tout
à l'heure j'ai fait sur sept exactement
l'homme qu'il nous faut
tu m'appeler et ben j j'ai pas entendu
c'est pas toi j'étais en train de
déboucher le tuyau va chercher à moment
with pas fait ce que je t'ai dit en tout
cas faut lui annoncer ça avec ménages où
ça vient six morts à face à trop traîner
tout de même
l'avion part dans une heure vingt à
parce que vous voulez qu'ils prennent
cet avion l'avait nous n'allons pas
laisser perdre de billets mais il
acceptera peut-être pas mais manquera
évidemment comme tu dis que tu parles
d'un coup de massue a quand même on ne
fait pas d'omelette sans casser des
oeufs
enfin s'ils ont dépensé le plus
doucement possible quand même bien sûr
qu'est ce que c'est que ces bouts de
papier oh ça se serait rien passé c'est
beaucoup c'est le pouvoir je vais signer
les rênes et la déchirer oui
avant même de savoir que je restais
c'est tout terre nous n'avons jamais été
des femmes d'argent c'est une autre
faiblesse c'est notre fierté
voilà mon rôle à la caisse qui va lui
annoncer ça pour moi c'est pas possible
c'est trop délicat pour moi aussi nous
laissez moi seul avec mais je lui
parlerai avec tout mon coeur oui tu
connais maman oui justement je ne veux
pas voir ça
julien me dit que vous avez quelque
chose à m'apprendre avec ménagement cdfa
des tout mon attention je n'en ai pas le
temps
asseyez vous fait peur
la minute qui commence va compter dans
votre vie attendez vous à une surprise
comme vous n'aurez jamais plus du siège
où vibrent centre je suis de plus en
plus inquiète pas moi je suis sûr de
votre décision d'ailleurs vous n'aurez
même pas en prendre une elle s'imposera
vous d'une manière éblouissante
alors voilà supposer qu on dise à un
homme mardi pourvu d'une situation en
moyenne dans laquelle ils ne s'amusent
pas tellement vous n'avez qu'un mot à
dire et c'est fini plus de femmes plus
de familles plus d'obligation vous vous
retrouvez dans une vie entièrement
nouvelle libre seul à l'autre bout du
moulin cabot traitement par dessus le
marché
alors ne me dites pas qu'il ya un homme
sur un million qui citerait que c'est
bon on va pas je te demande pas ton avis
c'est un armand me pose la question ce
sont des choses qui n'arrive que dans
les romans
et puis je ne vois pas en quoi ça me
concerne ça vous concerne ça vous
concerne avec une urgence extrême
si vous dites oui oui c'est pas très
compliqué à seulement oui dans une heure
vous êtes à roissy 12 heures après vous
débarquez à lima deux heures après midi
et el kala moor et vous restez là bâton
que vous voudrez libre seul directeur
gérant des grands chantiers fernandez le
plus insouciants célibataires du pérou
alors ne me dit pas mais indécis je
croirai quand c'est possible
n'est ce pas c'est pas possible que vous
ayez l'ombre d'une hésitation eux
d'autant plus que le temps presse je
n'hésite pas seulement c'est tellement
brutale à prendre comme ça d'un coup que
que je vais devoir quitter irène
vous devez comprendre ce que j'éprouve
un immense soulagement
je connais ma fille allait vivre avec
elle n'est pas une partie de plaisir
mais l'abandonné si brusquement je ne
voudrais pas qu'elle ait trop de chagrin
ne vous inquiétez pas pour irène shell a
choisi elle sait ce qu'elle fait parce
que c'est elle qui a choisi est évident
que voulez vous aviez leur venue par
barret du prestigieux laventure de la
réussite
ce sont des choses auxquelles les femmes
sont très sensibles vous ne pouviez pas
le laventure laventure si vous si moi
j'avais été dans la forêt vierge avec
des sauvages je me suis aussi
débrouiller lui il a eu l'occasion
ballon plus on n'a pas eu l'occasion il
l'a fait naître c'est beaucoup plus
difficile vous on vous l'offre
le grand trek il avait tiré sur son
passé vous le tir est aussi vous êtes
l'île maurice vous vous rendez pas
compte alors de ce qu'on vous propose
mais c'est comme si on vous disait que
devant vous la ne l'influencent pas
alors c'est oui ou c'est non attendez
c'est voir reprendre mes esprits c'est
tellement il espéré non je veux dire
inattendu leurs noms ne vous reprenez
pas inespéré c'est via le mans et bien
on n'y a pas de repères il faut annoncer
la bonne nouvelle à hirel lui faire vos
adieux et allait boucler votre manif
mais j'ai pas bizarre il faut sûrement
un visa parler au pérou nous allons
demander à daniel il le sera sûrement à
lui daniel
voila voila j'ai tout dit et il est
d'accord seulement il ya tout ce qui
l'ennuie c'est qu'il n'a pas de visa a
reconnu marc pas pensé à ça assis nazis
moi j'ai pensé comme un pas dans ce but
bien sûr non moi je me disais que armand
et moi nous aurions peut-être obligé de
faire la navette avec el kala ou et
j'avais révisé nos passeports at one a
alors tout est parfait on effraie vie
dont tu le prends bien maintenant oui
mais tout à l'heure il était
complètement effondré
enfin ne nous attendrit sont pas tout ça
est poignant mais le temps est un grand
médecin
oui le temps oui je compte beaucoup sur
le temps n'est que celui d'aller bien
votre machine vous accompagnant les
efforts d'accompagnement je préfère lui
seul vous savez ce que c'est on peut
être et but on risque de changer d'avis
de 20 dans la série glee série glee jeu
par le biais a lot of tuvéri papon
d'ivoire est pas laissé conter jouer sur
les fondamentaux et annoncez votre
arrivée quand même à votre situation
nous nous occupons de faire entièrement
confiance à l'épée chez moi je parle je
pars à irène
je garderai toujours de toi on va
et merci pour tout
tiens une perte au nom non pour tuer je
le mets la dans ma petite poche voilà
ébats et pas alors à dieu j'ai eu chaud
[Applaudissements]
il est parti j'ai pu y croire tout s'est
passé tellement vite dans ce cas là il
faut pas laisser les gens réfléchis mort
non ils ont tout le temps après ils ont
toute la vie toute la vie toute la vie
ici tous les deux
et oui alors que lui sera là bas tout
seul au pense pas à lui il chiffre à
habas rocchi siffle enfin je veux dire
c'est les premiers mois sans traduire
les premiers jours le départ le départ
est très très dur mais une fois qu'on
est dans l'avion vous savez c'est
tellement formidable l'avion c'est vrai
on a l'impression de tout laisser sur le
terrain ses soucis ses regrets on se
sent léger en vie quand il va arriver
là-bas lima le pérou c'est tellement
beau labrador a great thou non non mais
je me demande si je vais pouvoir me me
réadapter ici parce que la vache était
mon maître moi je faisais ce que je
voulais mais ici aussi tout ce que tu
voudras il le faudra bien nous n'avons
qu'une hâte c'est que vous repreniez la
maison ma dorénavant quand il y aura une
décision à prendre c'est toi tu te
regardes tu n'existes mans nous avons
une réponse à donner à crédit marine et
nous étions bien embarrassé oui c'est un
organisme qui vient se font dès qu'ils
nous demandent si nous voulons y adhérer
oui et la vente à crédit entraîne
forcément des complications de
comptabilité il faudrait engager au
moins un comptable de plus et alors
qu'est ce que tu en penses et à tous a
décidé jeudi faut pas hésiter à faire
des frais surtout quand ils sont
productifs comme on dit au pérou sam
l'argent par les fenêtres et poussera
des cadillac de ton jardin c'est ça qui
nous manque
vendredi vont alors vous êtes plutôt
patronat seulement mais cette façon nous
allons récupérer une clientèle dont vous
ne soupçonnez pour la porte en soi la
wii n'a pas hésité ce qu'il fallait et
j'ai un peu d'expérience je lui ai
téléphoné un pour leur dire que
contrairement à ce que vous aviez de
prendre daniel t'a dit de téléphonie on
a le temps non je crois qu'il vaut tout
de même mieux ne pas nous emballer vous
avez tout à fait raison dans ce procès
je voulais dire
il est normal qu'une feuille de
bousculer enfin les gens qui n'ont pas
les moyens de payer comptant énorme
alors les moyens de payer à crédit ça
tombe sous le sens ne s'agit pas leur
retraite qu'est ce qu'on peut dire c'est
bien l'europe où la marchandise est
naturellement naturellement ou le dit si
bien c'est le vendeur qui traque et
surtout quand il s'agit d'un kayak
quand il aura navigué dans les eaux plus
ou moins troubles de masse ou dita van
damme on voit du tout celle avantage de
mes nouveaux kayak payant on peut les
laver pour ils peuvent resservir après
1,9 en mai à vous verrez ça l'année
prochaine
c'est ça c'est ça numéro 5 mai prochain
c'est la levure raisonnable pour cette
année pas de vente à crête mais je crois
qu'il faudrait quand même
non non non non non non non il vaut
mieux attendre les nouveaux callas non
mais vous le savez c'est pas du tout ce
qu'ils voulaient dire pas que tu sais
mieux que lui ce qui voulait dire toi
c'est pourtant clair mon chéri mon chéri
qu'un soulagement que tu sois là tu es
tu es tellement l'âme de cette maison ou
alors ne lui fait pas trop de
compliments du grand des vanités non non
je me prends pas pour un aigle
si tu sais très bien ce que tu pour ne
fait pas de mode s
enfin nous allons pouvoir nous reposer
oui désormais lui décidera et nous nous
exécuterons cessa exécutons est d'abord
nous allons faire ce que vous avez dit
écrire à crédit marine que nous donnons
pas suite voilà et il faut voir comment
nous allons organiser le stockage est
avec toi tu ferais mieux corriger les
épreuves de catalogue avec papa il faut
donner le bon à tirer avant midi ce
message le lien peut s'en occuper tout
seul mais oui il sera encore ce soin et
la primaire le grand rien à ces
corrections et certaines en ont un
quand elle sort une idée on peut dire ce
qu'on veut c'est comme si on chantait
moi pas du tout pas du tout les gens
étaient le mont avila
d'ailleurs vous verrez dans les
prochaines avec les nouveaux kayak ce
sera exactement la même chose
elles feront ce qu'elles voudront aux
propos du tout faire avec elle mais
coûteux parce que j'ai plus l'habitude
de me laisser faire aussi non
comment les jivaros ce sont pas des gens
comme un daim et ben moi et m'ont pas
fait peur non ça y est évident qu'avec
les jivaros les coupeurs de têtes vaut
mieux pas les contrarier un me croyez
pas ça quand on leur parle avec autorité
et n'assiste pas vous savez peut-être en
tout cas leur petite cuisine
citoyennement sorcier vous savez pas ce
que une tête morte on en fait ce qu'on
en veut elle ne résiste pas à tandis que
réduire une tête vivante
on essaie tout travail ah bah oui c'est
même impossible non n'arrive
on y arrive seulement selon c'est plus
long oui on vous l'a vite comme ça un
petit peu chaque jour ou presque sans
vous en aperceviez elle devient toute
petite elle pèse plus rien ça y est
alors elle ne gêne plus du tout et c'est
ce qu'on m'a fait on m'a laissé l'attend
juste de quoi m'intéressait mais des
petites choses quoi mais pipe
mots croisés l'heure des repas eh ben
c'est très agréable
oui parce que vos petites têtes d'indian
ils sont bien tranquilles suspendu au
soleil devant l'iut pense plus à rien
mais alors plus rien ne venait troubler
c'est très agréable
moi je vais rien du tout je veux pas
qu'on me dise ma tête ça a déjà commencé
comment vous êtes vous avez déjà bien
réduit soit même que le plus gros est
fait ainsi taux n'est pas dans mes vous
étiez persuadé aujourd'hui que vous ne
repartirez pas est bas mais je suis
resté parce que j'ai bien voulu non vous
avez vous lu ce qu'elles ont bien voulu
mais depuis votre retour elle avait
décidé justement que vous ne repartirez
y est pas elles ont réussi
moi je vous le dis un mot jivaro ce à
côté d'elle c'est de la roupie de
sansonnet
mais qu'est ce que vous racontez là
c'est moi même qui ai pris ma résolution
ce matin d'ailleurs la preuve
marthe est là presque une syncope
chaque coffret on lâche tire mon chapeau
à b et armand il s'est attardé à partir
ma place oui pas du tout mais moi si
parce que j'ai été faire viser son
passeport il ya un mois son passeport et
celui d'hier elle m a dit elle a dit
c'était au cas où un rien qu'un
passeport un seul celui d'armand alors
elle serait prévu ça depuis le jour de
mon arrivée
et oui c'est pas beau ça
[Musique]
c'est incroyable ah oui c'est incroyable
j'ai croyez pas non plus d'ailleurs
je me suis dit daniel a tellement changé
c'est tellement ce qu'il veut rue ce né
sera pas entortillé et oui j'aurais
parié n'importe quoi j'aurais tellement
voulu gagner parce que parce que j'ai
beaucoup d'amitié pour inverser
oui si à tel point que la lundi dernier
quand marc m'a envoyé ailleurs france
pour chercher la place d'armand comment
lundi dernier j'ai fait une chose qui
m'a étonnée moi-même avant que dans en
ce qui suppose idiote
j'ai pris en plus une place pour vous
non si ces nouvelles six fils et la
place à côté d'armand bogota parce que
ça serait terrible
d'ailleurs maintenant il est trop tard
mais non il est peut-être pas trop tard
mais chez l'homme des décisions rapides
et quelle heure est il
les tensions 20 et ben alors mais
l'avion perd dans une demie et va
justement en 20 minutes avec un taxi je
peux tu as roi c'est moi je les entends
à bayonne
oui vous avez raison c'est trop tard
parce qu'il faudrait trouver un prétexte
pour sortir et de vente elle joue serait
pas c'est trop tard je suis comme un
riche et bien c'est dommage ou sous les
sabots et oui elle dans ces deux minutes
dans 5 minutes tu veux dire est ce que
vous allez fabriquer ya de fait comment
non parce qu'on vous parlait alors leur
permet de choses et est donc presque
faut que je me mette au courant - ben
voyons tu as tout le temps dont le plus
précieux c'est le catalogue assieds toi
même pas mis le prix du pack daniel va
aller passer des cigarettes des
cigarettes et oui des cigarettes elle le
bureau de tabac et là il est juste au
coin de la rue il est en face de la
station de taxis il y en a toujours à
cette heure-ci des gauloises
plouffe a tout de suite
attristé
quel empressement on nous l'a rendu
riche ça commence pas trop mal non
je crois même qu'il est sûre sur le
manche 1 à vous qui me doit une fière
chandelle à la les pas des doubles et
les magasins douala si je ne devais pas
secouer comme je lé fais tu laissé
partir avec les battre en ce moment un
lit roulerait vers l'aéroport
et toi tu seras en train de pleurer
alors commence par un 110 avoue que son
département est tout de même quelque
chose
et alors j'avais commencé avec espérer
mais arte à cette obstination c'était
intolérable
bonjour n'arrive à pleurer mois il faut
vraiment que savent plus quoi faire 11
53 20 quels articles et dossiers
pneumatiques si on est un peu dans
l'état où ils sont depuis l'an dernier
wick a plus l'impression mais voit à
trier les médias pour l'instant les
regonfler les autres discrètement de
temps en temps tu n'as pas de regret de
baisser les prix papa forme et non
d'avoir choisi daniel il serait un peu
tard pour en aviser
oui et puis fisher et muscade genève
j'allais voir les restes ici ne va pas
se perdre
on peut nommer j'espère bien alors les
dérives de 185
l'essentiel c'est que là-bas armand soit
à la hauteur oui avec nous derrière ça
allait mais tout seul être quelqu'un
là-bas à côté de lui pour le conseiller
en tout cas avec un vent de pouvoir
avoir toute confiance avec sale affaire
d'amérique est en de bonnes mains
en somme nous avons fait d'une pierre
deux coups où exactement
en définitive tout ça ça commence pas
trop ce qui fige à la vie cigarette jeté
des pierres de mots quand tu vas revenir
moi j'ai quelque chose à vous dire tiens
un geste qui le flat près de lui donc
assigné le bon à tirer du catalogue
mon dieu je m'excuse insisté nez mais
j'ai eu une révélation à vous faire
quelle révélation
voilà il est 11 heures 10 minutes et
alors
daniel est sorti pour aller chercher des
cigarettes
tu ne te sens pas bien
c'est curieux c'est curieux comme les a
même à parler pour ne rien dire
non non non je vais parler mais je ne
sera pas pour ne rien dire
oh non et ben alors je sens que ça va
vous intéresser
tu t'avances beaucoup voilà je disais de
daniel est parti chercher des cigarettes
ont vaqué chevret annoncé cet idiot il
était 11 heures 6 je me suis trompé j'ai
pris la petite et la grande la petite
aiguille à la place de l'annoncé la
grande que j'ai pris à la place de la
petite les frites les aiguilles d'une du
minutes tu sais mais les minutes du
compteur mais en fait j'étais bredouille
c'est quelque chose à dire tu vas bien
qu l'empêcherait de travailler où
veux-tu en arriver là mais je savais
plus ce que je disais mais ça va me
revenir dans quelques noms j'en étais au
bureau de tabac qui est au coin de la
rue allez part je t'écoute
bon voilà je disais le dos daniel
hyperburo tabac pour acheter des
cigarettes
si par hasard et ne trouvaient pas ce
qu'il veut dans ce bureau de tabac
l'acte il y en a un autre qui est du
côté de l'avenue de joinville as tu sais
c'est plus madame destin qui ne tient
pas ce qu'elle a vendu vendu avant tout
ça madame trista sais pas qui moi non
plus mais il paraît que ça doit nous
intéresser
si ça peut vous intéresser mais je pense
bien pensé qu'à l'heure actuelle il est
dû à la toussaint les du côté de gonesse
c'est très intéressant ce connaissent
mais je vous crois mes enfants qui a des
plantes assure deux tulipes unique en
france
j'invite les plantations de toutes les
couleurs à perte de vue
et puis il ya aussi des chants des
champs de glaïeuls énorme
il ne s'est pas livrée hier qu'ils sont
là parce que eux ils ont de la taille
normale non c'est deschamps des
champions
non et alors de là-haut vite là où ça
doit être superbe et puis il ya autre
chose encore qui influe aegon et 512
veut c'est la proximité du grand
aéroport de famille de roissy charles de
gaulle parti maintenant non pas encore
il décolle dans 50 secondes
les moteurs sont en marche et on a
retiré l'échelle assis le départ
d'armand qu'il met dans cet état là et
tout à coup un homme surgit nue tête
comme ça sans bagages ils font sur la
piste ils escaladent l'échelle il fait
naître dans la carlingue
on referme la porte pour nom et l'avion
roule doucement tout doucement il va
décoller il va décoller ça y est il a
déconné le monsieur est sauvée au iv il
est parti monsieur daniel autant la
partie cigarettes
qu'est ce que tu dis c'est une
plaisanterie est stupide mais par nous
voyons oui daniel j'ai dû des parties il
est là tout à l'heure il a pris un taxi
s'est fait conduire à roissy il est
monté dans l'avion qui partait pour
l'amérique
didier les à côtés d'armand voilà et
puis il est parti reviendra plus jamais
un an ça y est ça y est je vois vous
avez compris
c'est absurde m'acheter des cigarettes
si ce sera attendais pas je te vois tu
donc déjà fait une demi heure plus cher
précise pas il peut courir parce que
pour attraper la dame au chapeau qui
l'est déjà 1 5 km julien je te préviens
que c'est une farce que vous avez
manigancé tous les deux ponts de faire
peur
tu n'en fera pas partie bon je te jure
que daniel est parti les parties il est
parti
rousseau la vitre d'un taxi à à ce que
tu savais qu'ils allaient s'en aller
attendu pour nous prévenir qu'il soit
trop tard mais j'ai essayé de vous le
dire mais vous m'avez pas laisser parler
on avait coupé la parole comme vous le
faites toujours et il se serait décidée
comme ça brusquement tient pas il avait
juste le temps et comment j'ai pu partir
ils n'avaient pas de billets je n'avais
plus rien le 8 jours et tu étais au
courant maintenant il l'a dit juste tout
à l'heure le groupe ya dix jours il
avait pris son vieil ami joué moi mais
c'est pas possible il peut pas deviner
que celui que nous avions pu y était
pour armand et ben ils vous parlent
aussi ailleurs
il m'a dit qu'il savait tout savez tout
oui il m'a dit je les ai laissés aller
comme ça un peu pour voir pour rigoler
un peu selon les propres termes
c'est un curieux garçons quand même j'ai
pleuré devant lui et pendant que je le
croyais mais il m'a laissé aller il se
payait ma tête mais toi conte et arrive
à croire que tu les mets c'est lui qui
l'a cru
jean bart à ça pendant un moment il a
cru dans celui-ci non non non non non il
n'est jamais couper une seconde dans
cette histoire là d'ailleurs il me dit
une chose et jaune assez bizarre a tant
vu que je me souvienne il m'a dit il
règne s'aime tellement que si elle avait
quelqu'un d'autre elle serait jalouse
d'elle même en face et c'est insensé ya
une heure nous tenons là dans la main
comme un guignol
il voulait faire la vente à crédit on
lui disait non il cligne mba obame en
sept attrapés en face de toi c'est
peut-être justement ça qui l'a décidée
parce qu'il m'a dit avec elle c'est
comme si on n'était pas là alors c'est
pas la peine d'être qu'est ce que je te
dis c est qu a voulu aller trop vite tu
n'a pas ménagé son amour propre et les
blessures d'amour propre
ça ne pardonne pas ah non non ça
pardonne pas et cette fois ci je vous
jure qu'il nomme le payer parce que le
pays est avec quoi va-t-il tel payer tu
avais un pouvoir qui prend des
maîtresses et la sphère de la déchirer
tu as cru l'éblouir pinton ges il a dû
bien rire et oui pas en tant que moi
parce que le pouvoir j'ai déchiré ce
n'était pas le bon c'était l'ancien au
machu que même face à l'as point d'un tu
as pensé à ça c'est merveilleux opi tout
ce que je t'ai dis bien les torts ne pas
te faire confiance tu es vraiment ma
fille oui
merci bon maintenant on travaille j'ai
plus de cigarettes
je vais te chercher à attaquer
reste ici
téléphone au contremaître y allait
perdre est oui en est et très serviable
ce garçon il se fera un plaisir d'y
aller heureusement qu'il est là entre
bardèche parce que nous ne serons pas
trop de trois avec tout le travail qu'il
va y avoir un garçon sérieux appui de
bien élever hermès qu'est ce que tu en
penses irène berne est il eu pas mal et
puis ce n'est pas une forte tête lui non
on pourra en faire quelque chose alors
et rodez
[Applaudissements]
la pièce que nous avons joué pour vous
ce soir est de messieurs andré gillois
et max régner
le décor et de roger hart
les costumes de donald cardwell
[Musique]
avec jean bergé
francis lattes
geneviève fontanel
roland armentel
hélène duc
mise en scène de michel hook
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]